hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast how can sell in one
technology help you automate cell line
development it is presented by Barbara
Macintosh vice president of business
development at signee on alba simon
marketing manager at sign neon and gam
20-year the scientific and general
director at selling neon I am Judy
Oracle averts and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots lab roots is a
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone the
savannahs interactive we encourage you
to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming
Barbara Macintosh Alba Simon nd M 20 ere
I will now turn the presentation over to
them
you verily for this nice introduction so
today I'm going to present felon what
you can be used mage of cell line
development one crucial point in cell
line development is the ability to
isolate single cells the main challenge
in single cell isolation is to be able
to dispense only single cells and
maintain those cells alive and this as a
number of application this application
can be split in two groups the group of
single cell analytics so where we want
to analyze and this is useful when
analyzing for example tumor tissue where
we know that there is a very large the
ordinate II of the sample and single
cell analysis will help you to obtain a
more detailed and comprehensive picture
of the cells that are containing the
tumor as compared to a traditional
method that would just give you an
average value of the cell containing
that bulk on the other hand isolation of
single cell is a useful whenever you're
undertaking cloning steps and this can
be used for monoclonal antibody
development stem cell line development
and in application of gene editing for
example using CRISPR caste 9 one aspect
that is very important when you're doing
single cell isolation is to understand
the aspect of Poisson distribution
poisson distribution is actually a
probability and this probability give
you an indication of the likelihood for
you to find a single cell in a given
volume or hot spot when working when
doing limiting division for example
which is a most common technique to
clone yourself people will typically
work at a fairly divided concentration
in order to ensure that they limit the
number of wells which will contain more
than one single cell because as you know
if you have more than one single cells
and you will need to reclone so do a
second step which is a great loss of
time over the years
we people have developed a number of
technologies to isolate single self and
I'm now going to describe the different
technologies that have been developed so
there is a number of technologies that
are fast such as the fax but they
typically suffer for some from some
drawbacks so for example fax very quick
however due to I share forces most of
the cells that are coming out of a fax
are typically not alive or in poor shape
then you have the technologies using the
person distribution such as the
automated liquid under or microfluidic
encapsulation as described before this
technology are typically very quick
however only a small proportion of the
well my quattro platform will contain a
single cell on the other hand you have
some technologies that are more precise
but these are typically hard to automate
and fairly slow so this can be like
laser capture microdissection or
acoustic and optical tweezers another
way of seeing those type of technology
is on the plot so we've plotted the
precision versus throughput on the
bottom right you can see the
technologies that focus on distribution
Michael dope lead generation traditional
liquid are now and on the top left
technologies that are precise but slow
so such as laser capture and acoustic
and optical tweezers the technology that
we have developed is standing in between
those so it offer a very good precision
while maintaining a Sally eyes who put
and it's based on kids acoustic
dispensing and visual feedback and now
Barbara Macintosh is going to present to
you the technology on which all these
selling one was based
Thank You diem so to talk about the
technology days of dispensing technology
I want to go back in time just a little
bit so [ __ ] on is an actual daughter
company of our parent Sai neon and so
neon is focusing on that single cell
applications whereas Sai neon is based
in Berlin and is focused on ultra low
drop precision dispensing for a variety
of applications in both the diagnostic
in the life science marketplace with
this technology we're able to dispense
non-contact a variety of different
content if you will
anything from DNA to proteins to
particles and as you can see living
cells
so within signee we dispense folk cells
at once to do specific applications but
as we got more specific in single cell
work we that's when we spun out their
daughter company selenium with the
technology as well you can dispense to
any type of support so they're doing
nitrocellulose membranes or a fly or a
microtiter plate or even a wafer because
the dispensing is non-contact it's very
much what we call an open platform
the benefits of dispensing non-contact
the obvious one is you don't physically
come in contact with the surface so you
don't damage it like something if it's a
coated slide or nitrocellulose but but
also and very critical when you're
scaling is the reproducibility the
reproducibility of non-contact
dispensing is far superior than any
other type but with our technology we
have the droplets free-falling and as
they come in contact with the substrate
and or other reagents they have a very
high efficiency of mixing so with the
technology that piezo dispensing piezo
technology works by having a voltage
applied to a crystal and what happens is
the crystal is squeezed and small
droplets are ejected very quickly our
technology allows us to Spence down in
the Pico liter range as small as 50 Pico
liters per drop but it goes up to a
range of 800 Pico leaders and although
that might seem very small we dispense
very fast a thousand Hertz or up to a
thousand Hertz which means you depends a
thousand drops a second so very quickly
we can get up into the nano liter range
which is very attractive for single cell
dispensing
you
the next slide you see actually an image
so this is this is an image of the piezo
nozzle and although it's sideways you
see a droplet being ejected from it this
is also a screen capture of the software
where it calculates the drop volume you
can see in the corner it's 285 Pico
leaders but also very good quality
control parameters like the CV of that
dispense and you can very quickly save
these files as part of your quality
control and so this is these are one of
the cameras that we use on our standard
platforms but we've also incorporated it
into this technology this next this next
image you can see it's a video and it's
actually showing the droplet being
ejected lifetime but it is available on
the Semyon website the second camera on
the system is what we call target
recognition
it's a CCD camera and we use it a lot in
diagnostic applications because it's
registering a fiducial and it's moving
relative to it to enable very precise
dispensing to a location and again very
very beneficial for the cell in one
technology because we once we see the
cell traveling through the nozzle we
then move the dispense to the target
position
this next video is showing a variety of
different dispense applications from
anything to a small drop to pattering an
area with an array you see the tasks run
going and capturing the drop in front of
the stroboscopic camera calculating the
volume and then moving and placing that
drop to a different substrate it's
calculating standard deviation you're
able to pattern spots change the volume
and coat an area or do a variety of
different patterns
you
so as you can see from the video this
technology enables a variety of
different applications you can dispense
into a microtiter plate and take a
traditional Eliza and make it a
multiplex Eliza allowing you more data
with less volume of reagents we can
dispense with a microfluidic tip with
blister packing a transdermal patch a
wafer to do different types of
diagnostics because all of it is using
the piezo dispensing
sorry I'm just my slide isn't advancing
so with the piezo dispensing that's what
we incorporated into the cell in one and
now you'll able to see some of the
hardware and the software features that
we use in our core technology and how
we're enabling it for just single cell
dispensing so game I'll give this back
to you for the next segment Thank You
Barbara so I'm just going to present you
the different steps that have been taken
to develop these new technologies so we
thought from a kids or acoustic
dispenser as described by Barbara and we
have this optical automated optical
monitoring system and basically this
work has been done around two years ago
it was initiated with the collaboration
with the University of British Columbia
and there we started by studying the
behavior of cells inside different
geometry of dispenser and by optimizing
the geometry of dispenser we could
reduce the number of phenomenon that
could happen to only two phenomenon
which is which we translate as travel or
ejection as you will see on the next
slide the size of the ejection zone the
Green Zone on this dispenser is actually
the area where whenever we have a single
cell in that area we know that this
single cell will be contained in the
next droplet that will be generated
another thing we have to take into
consideration is the fact that cells or
any particles suspended in a suit in a
medium with lower density will tend to
sediment we implemented a sedimentation
zone this is to account for the fact
that the cells will sediment in between
the time we detect them in front of the
camera to the time we go to the target
and basically this give rise to four
different scenarios the scenario we are
looking for is to obtain a single cell
in the ejection zone with no cell in the
sedimentation
whenever this is happening we move the
dispenser to the target and we dispense
the other three scenarios are we have an
empty ejection zone so this droplet is
discarded second thing I second scenario
would be we have multiple cell in the
ejection then obviously we don't want
multiple cell so we will also discard
this droplet and finally if you have a
single cell in the ejection zone but you
also have a single cell in the
sedimentation zone by safety we will
also discard is droplet when I say
discarding one thing that is very
important is that we discard those into
a recovery tube so the cells could be
further aspirated and repossessed if is
desired and now you're going to get an
animation that's going to describe to
you the way the system ii x1 system is
working
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
so you've just seen how the salon 1x1
works
so we sp8 a sample from a multiple plate
for example then go in front of the
camera under thank undertake and
automated mapping steps from this
mapping step we determine the size of
the ejection sedimentation and travel
zone and we start processing the your
sample now on the next slide what you
will see is actually what is happening
on the software and inside the machine
so not anymore an animation but real
life and this is an example that has
been processed using prostate cancer
cells and on there you will see on the
right part is what is recorded by the
software life and it's you have a
synchronized image on the left of what
is happening in the dispenser so
whenever the image will freeze on the
right it means that the dispenser has
detected the single cells the head is
moving to the target and dispensing SL
so I'm just going to start it now
you
so what you just saw on this video was
actually so single-cell being isolated
and dispensed into micro Wells onto a
microscope slides and out of 400
position field 98% of the world
positions 394 contained a single cell
and this was filled in about 18 minutes
one very important thing with this
technology that people really enjoy is
the fact that they can see live their
sample being processed unlike a site
ometer where you only only get a signal
on the selling one you can actually
analyze your sample these are a number
of aggregates debris and so on and all
these images are recorded and can be
used for further quality control and now
my colleague Alba Simone is going to
present to you the kind of results that
have been obtained with this technology
Thank You GM so we have seen the
background of the technology and how the
gentle dispensing is able to maintain
and isolate single cells and now I would
like to go into details of some of the
results that we have compiled the month
from the machine from the salon one so
just to recall what we mentioned at the
beginning by limiting dilution which is
following the Poisson distribution we
were fairly limited to 25 percent of
single souther drop
whereas with our technology we are
reaching up to 98% up to 100 percent
most of the time single cells and that
have been shown in this to nice arrays
where single cells from dissociated
lung-cancer asteriod
were isolated into microscope slide and
that's the left side and on the right
side we'll see the isolation of
fluorescence microbead of 21 microns of
diameter
and we see in both sides that we reach
100% of single cell in each position we
show as first of all is a highly precise
system allowing the isolation of the
single cell and is also precise in the
sense that we can reach very narrow
position such as isolating cells in 50
microns micro wells in this picture
showing on the top fluorescence micro
beads and on the below part Ella cells
now we do several experiments with
different type cells because we want to
have a look if there is a different type
that would be also as successful
independently of the cell type and we
find out actually that we could reach a
very high accuracy with fibroblasts CH
o--'s and etc a fairly high amount of
different cells and always find in
single cell in each position so we jump
in into one of the applications that we
are focusing today which is cloning and
we've already mentioned the main
challenges of this application which is
first of all we want to find only single
cells and we of course want these cells
to stay alive so we have defined clonal
recovery as a percentage of wealth which
will be contained in single colony after
an examined of time
sorry
um so do
- surely describe how does it look like
when you are at the lab doing the cell
line development you will have to
undergo first of all the genetic
modification of the cell than to do
culture of two weeks and then start with
the planning on the left side we see how
the process with the limiting dilution
you will have to do several steps and
repeat these steps in order to obtain a
high amount of best clones and at the
end we have estimated that you will
spend around ten weeks with our system
in a comparative experiment we basically
reach monoclonal t after only two wraps
of culture after two times two weeks so
after a month we will able to have very
good results in mono clonality so we
basically save time we basically save as
well media and consumables so
still having a very good outcome with
this system
then what we followed was extreme and
where we after the isolation of the
cells we culture for seven days and we
find out that an average 84 percent of
the welds contain single-cell colonies
in comparison with what we would have
obtained by limiting dilution so manual
would be limited to 25% ending up on
having to do several step because we
will had multiple colonies after each
step in order to reach the monofin ality
at the end now we mentioned that feature
and is actually something that it's very
useful when doing cloning recording all
the all the isolation step itself
meaning that the user can follow up in
life the trajectory of the cell from the
when he is when the cell is in the
capillary till it reach its target
meaning that you see on the left side
the picture a 1 a very clear cell which
will end up on an a1 well on your plate
so you have live data thanks to the
camera which is recorded prior
dispensing and that you can find after
in the files and then go back and check
how was your experiment just to document
results
and as you can see on the below picture
if we clear that in that case a double
cell a doublet will be dispensed so
therefore discarded in our recovery tube
now we did a last round of experiments
with one of our partners externally and
we wanted to compare
we wanted to compare how our system sell
and one will behave compared to a fax so
we start the experiment the aim was to
clone and to look at only the negative
cells the GFP negative cells from a CH
or cell media starting point was only 70
percent of this population was the
population of interest because only 70
percent were negative so looking at
where the fax can do we know that the
fact will sort and we looked only at 70
at only at the negative cell meaning
100% of the cells will be negative gfp
whereas our system will look at the full
amount of the cell cells meaning that a
maximum which is expected to be cfp
negative are 70% well then we we did the
Culture Media after 5 days and we found
out that actually with the salon one
system we reach it this 76% of outgrowth
so the ability cells which were alive
whereas with the fax only 38% were alive
and this is showing us that during the
isolation process the fax area 3
basically underwent a high stress for
the cells which make them not to survive
in contrast with our system cell n1 was
ensuring that all isolated single cells
were maintained alive so reaching a
fairly high percentage of viability now
a lot of person we looked at is we know
that our system is able to control the
temperature of the target so we
basically did several experiment at 4
degrees at 20 degrees and 37 degrees and
we found out that cooling the target
four degrees was actually proven a
higher a clonal recovery till 87% so if
you have to do planning experiment we
will recommend you to go to four degrees
now just to finish up with some of the
results we recently got was looking at
isolation of mouse neural stem cells
using our tool and one and as you can
see in the picture the results are
already very promising 97% of cells
where a single cell only 2% were empty
and only one was double so just to
summarize the main benefits of our
technology we will look at a system that
it's a very versatile which is accurate
you will isolate 100 up to 100% of
sangil cells it will keep it alive so
keeping a very high amount of viability
it is an open system you can use any of
you consumables of your choice and we
are reaching a high throughput a fast
isolation process as an example 90
single cells were isolated in less than
four minutes so now in this presentation
we just focus on cloning but as you know
our system has several other
applications and you can have a look at
our website www.engvid.com the bins send
that we thank you very much for your
attention and you have here our further
information details email and phone and
just to finish off with a little touch
the logo you see below is a live logo
meaning printed live living cells
thank you very much for your attention
and now we are open for a discussion
Thank You Barbara Elba and km for your
informative presentations we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box it appears on your screen
and click the send button will answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get started
the first question is what are the
overall benefits of your technology
I'll take this one if you want G I'm
sticking here so we have a number of
unique benefits from our technology I'll
try and summarize them quickly but as
you've seen they accurate which provides
which entry order to obtain only single
cell being a gentle using this acoustic
technology we ensure very high
variability it is fully automated it
provides you with data that you can
record which are important for monitor
analogy proof of Mon Oakland ID so you
can record images we have temperature
control which allow an even more
enhanced variabilities and the important
it's an open platform so you choose the
type of consumables that you want to use
who is using your technology reference
clients
so sorry this is Barbara so the
technology itself has been in the
marketplace for a variety of different
applications from as I mentioned earlier
life science to Diagnostics and you can
see some of our clients on that slide
from both academia to full-on
commercialization because the technology
is scaleable now specifically to the
cell in one technology we've
collaborated with a number of clients to
enable both software development and
proof-of-concept applications using a
variety of different cells and and
development which cells or particles
were successfully isolated with cell in
one technology
so he is either speaking so basically we
have reached a very good results an
isolation any particles or cells from
one to about 40 microns diameter these
cells are the major group are mammalian
cells going from B cells th ohk
hybridomas neural stem cells lymphocytes
tumor cells CT sees a Patou blast and
primary fiberglass for example and but
we are also undertaking proof of concept
for cells including bacterial cells and
G's for example and we have of course
dispenses bar-coded normal beats used in
sequencing like the mckusker beads for
example I would like to once again thank
Barbara Macintosh Alba Simon and diem
Tornai for their tawny air for their
presentations would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through July 12 2018 you'll receive an
email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
when your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that is all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye